Our episodes deal with serious and often distressing incidents. If you feel at any time you need support, please contact your local crisis centre. For suggested phone numbers for confidential support, please see the show notes for this episode on your app or on our website. This episode was originally released on case files Patreon, Apple Premium and Spotify Premium feeds as an early bonus for our paid subscribers. These episodes are designed to be slightly shorter, allowing us to cover a broader range of cases. are designed to be slightly shorter, allowing us to cover a broader range of cases. To receive these episodes early and dad-free, you can support CaseFile on your preferred platform.
我们的剧集涉及严肃且往往令人痛苦的事件。如果您在任何时候感到需要支持，请联系您当地的危机中心。如需获取保密支持的电话号码，请查看您应用中或我们网站上的本集节目说明。本集最初发布在 Casefile 的 Patreon、Apple Premium 和 Spotify Premium 订阅源上，作为付费订阅者的早期福利。这些剧集旨在缩短时长，以便我们涵盖更广泛的案件。为了提前且无广告地收听这些剧集，您可以在您偏好的平台上支持 Casefile。
Growing up in the English city of Bradford, Semya Shahid was a typical high-spirited girl. She enjoyed fashion and fast cars, was popular, funny and headstrong. Simea's family fully supported her endeavors, especially her father, Mahomed. There was no question that Simea was a daddy's girl. The Shahid family were well known around Bradford. Simea's parents ran a limousine and car service business. One of her uncles owned a fishing chip shop and another the local florist. The Shahid family tree also extended to their ancestral home of Pandori, a small village in the Punjab region of Pakistan.
萨米亚·沙希德（Samia Shahid）在英国布拉德福德市长大，是一个典型的活泼女孩。她喜欢时尚和快车，性格开朗、风趣且固执。萨米亚的家人全力支持她的追求，尤其是她的父亲马霍梅德（Mahomed）。毫无疑问，萨米亚是父亲的掌上明珠。沙希德一家在布拉德福德很有名。萨米亚的父母经营着一家豪华轿车和汽车服务公司。她的一位叔叔拥有一家炸鱼薯条店，另一位则经营着当地的花店。沙希德家族的族谱还延伸到了他们的祖籍地——巴基斯坦旁遮普地区的潘多里（Pandori）小村庄。
Simea and her younger sister Medih, were given latitude to enjoy their western upbringing, though only up to a point. The Shahids remained true to their Sunni Muslim faith and Pakistani heritage. In 2012, as Simea reached her mid-twenties, her parents felt it was time for her to settle down and marry. Although arranged marriages weren't required by the Sunni faith, they were encouraged, if not expected, through Pakistani tradition. Samir wanted to make her family happy and proud and was open to the idea.
萨米亚和她的妹妹梅迪哈（Medih）在成长过程中享有一定的自由，可以享受西方的生活方式，但仅限于一定程度。沙希德一家始终忠于他们的逊尼派穆斯林信仰和巴基斯坦传统。2012年，当萨米亚二十多岁时，她的父母认为她该安定下来结婚了。虽然逊尼派信仰并不强制包办婚姻，但巴基斯坦传统对此不仅鼓励，甚至视为理所当然。萨米亚想让家人感到幸福和骄傲，因此对这个想法持开放态度。
Muhammad Shahid chose a man named Chaudhry Shaqil to be his daughter's husband. Sameer was less than enthused. Shaqil lived in Pandori and had just been released from prison for a non-fatal shooting of another man over a land dispute. He was also Sameer's first cousin. Marriages between first cousins in the British Pakistani community weren't our common. Sameer's parents were first cousins and had an enduring and loving marriage. They just wanted what they thought was best for their daughter. Simea put on a happy face around her family and appeared willing to give her upcoming
穆罕默德·沙希德（Muhammad Shahid）为女儿选定的丈夫名叫乔杜里·沙基尔（Chaudhry Shaqil）。萨米亚对此并不热心。沙基尔住在潘多里，刚因一起土地纠纷引发的非致命枪击案出狱。他还是萨米亚的表亲。在英籍巴基斯坦社区，表亲通婚并不罕见。萨米亚的父母就是表亲，他们的婚姻持久而美满。他们只是想为女儿做他们认为最好的选择。萨米亚在家人面前装出开心的样子，似乎愿意为即将到来的
marriage her best shot. Plants were made for her to travel to Pakistan for the wedding. Though, when speaking with her friends, Simea was plagued with concerns. She sought to live a happy life, but couldn't see this happening with the Chordry Shaquille. In the weeks leading up to her departure, Simea sent multiple messages to her friends expressing her growing despair. In one, she wrote, I'm dying, I swear. My life's a joke. Samia arrived in Pakistan in mid-February 2012.
婚姻尽最大努力。家人为她前往巴基斯坦结婚做了安排。然而，在与朋友交谈时，萨米亚却充满了担忧。她渴望过上幸福的生活，但她无法想象与乔杜里·沙基尔在一起会幸福。在出发前的几周里，萨米亚给朋友发了多条信息，表达了她日益增长的绝望。其中一条写道：“我快死了，我发誓。我的生活简直是个笑话。”2012年2月中旬，萨米亚抵达巴基斯坦。
Determined to not to upset her family, she threw herself into the task of planning her wedding. She bought her outfit and jewelry from the Pakistani Bazaar and fined you in every detail of the event. Her father paid for everything she needed. Sameer wed Chordry Shaqil in a four-day ceremony in front of hundreds of guests. As a wedding gift to his new son-in-law, Sameer's father gave Shaqil the house next door to the Shahid family home in Pandori. After the wedding, Samir and Shaqil moved in.
为了不让家人难过，她全身心地投入到婚礼筹备中。她在巴基斯坦集市购买了服装和珠宝，并敲定了活动的每一个细节。她的父亲支付了她所需的一切费用。萨米亚在数百名宾客的见证下，与乔杜里·沙基尔举行了为期四天的婚礼。作为给新女婿的结婚礼物，萨米亚的父亲将潘多里沙希德家隔壁的房子送给了沙基尔。婚礼结束后，萨米亚和沙基尔搬进了那栋房子。
Four months later in June, Samir returned to Bradford without her new husband. Shaqil intended to migrate to the UK, so Samer assisted with his application for a spousal visa. Their marriage, ceremony known as a Nika Runder Islam, was in accordance with Pakistan's Sharia Law. It therefore qualified as a legally recognized marriage under British law. However, Sameer's friends noted that she was a shell of her former self. Although Shaqil was nearly 4,000 miles away, Semya felt like she was under his constant
四个月后的六月，萨米亚独自回到了布拉德福德，没有带上她的新婚丈夫。沙基尔打算移民英国，因此萨米亚协助他申请了配偶签证。他们的婚姻，即伊斯兰教法中的“尼卡”（Nika），符合巴基斯坦的伊斯兰教法。因此，它在英国法律下也被视为合法认可的婚姻。然而，萨米亚的朋友们注意到，她已经变得形同枯槁。尽管沙基尔远在近4000英里之外，萨米亚却感觉自己一直处于他的
surveillance. He insisted that they video call and remain in contact every day. Semya felt trapped and soon fell into depression. Within a matter of weeks she told her friends that she wanted to die. With her husband's visa application still being processed, Samia returned to Pakistan in December. She continued to living with Shikil, but her feelings towards him didn't change. Six months later, Sama flew back to England.
监视之下。他坚持要求他们每天视频通话并保持联系。萨米亚感到被困住了，很快陷入了抑郁。几周之内，她告诉朋友她想死。由于丈夫的签证申请仍在处理中，萨米亚于12月回到了巴基斯坦。她继续与沙基尔生活在一起，但她对他的感情没有任何改变。六个月后，萨米亚飞回了英国。
It wasn't long before her friends began to notice a positive change. Simea seemed more like her former self. She was once again talkative, sociable and cheerful. She soon revealed her reason for this. In October, Simea was out to dinner in London with a group of friends, when she met a man named Sayed Mukta Khazm, known as Ali. Ali had only been visiting London for a short time. He was also a dual-Bredish and Pakistani national, but he lived and worked in Dubai.
没过多久，她的朋友们就开始注意到她有了积极的变化。萨米亚看起来更像以前的自己了。她再次变得健谈、善于交际且开朗。她很快透露了原因。10月，萨米亚在伦敦与一群朋友共进晚餐时，遇到了一位名叫赛义德·穆克塔·卡兹姆（Sayed Mukhtar Kazm）的男子，大家都叫他阿里（Ali）。阿里当时只是在伦敦短暂停留。他也是英国和巴基斯坦双重国籍，但在迪拜生活和工作。
Ali and Simea remained in contact and formed a close platonic friendship, opening up about all aspects of their lives, including Simea's unwanted marriage. Ali and Simea's feelings for one another developed into a romance, and by 2014 they were in love. Around the same time, Simea's husband's UK visa application was rejected. Consequently, Simea knew that her family would expect her to spend much more of her time in Pakistan. She didn't want this life for herself.
阿里和萨米亚保持联系，并建立了亲密的柏拉图式友谊，向对方敞开心扉谈论生活的方方面面，包括萨米亚那段不想要的婚姻。阿里和萨米亚对彼此的感情发展成了浪漫恋情，到2014年，他们相爱了。大约在同一时间，萨米亚丈夫的英国签证申请被拒。因此，萨米亚知道她的家人会期望她花更多时间待在巴基斯坦。她不想过这样的生活。
Hoping that Shaqil would accept the futility of their marriage, Simea aroused him for a divorce. He refused. Simea turned to the protection of Islam. Under Sharia law, a marriage is valid only if both parties give their free consent. This must come without any physical, psychological, financial, or emotional pressure, otherwise the marriage can be considered to be forced and declared void. Simea visited a Bradford mosque and spoke with the prayer leader also referred to as the Imam. She revealed that she'd been pressured into marriage by her family.
萨米亚希望沙基尔能接受他们婚姻的徒劳，于是向他提出离婚。他拒绝了。萨米亚转而寻求伊斯兰教的保护。根据伊斯兰教法，婚姻只有在双方自愿的情况下才有效。这必须在没有任何身体、心理、经济或情感压力的情况下进行，否则婚姻可被视为强迫婚姻并被宣布无效。萨米亚走访了布拉德福德的一座清真寺，并与领祷人（也称为伊玛目）进行了交谈。她透露自己是被家人强迫结婚的。
The Imam attempted to contact Chaudhry Shaqil for his side of the story, but he never responded. As a result, Simea's marriage to Shaqil was declared void. Simea kept this news from her family and discreetly began planning a future with Ali. A little over four months later, the pair wedded. They presented themselves at the home of the Bradford-based Imam who avoided Samir's previous marriage. Samir was happy, smiling and singing throughout the ceremony. Seventeen days later, the newlyweds completed the British legal formalities by signing the marriage register. Ali soon had to travel back to his home in Dubai for work. Samia had to wait for her spousal visa application
伊玛目试图联系乔杜里·沙基尔听取他的说法，但他从未回应。结果，萨米亚与沙基尔的婚姻被宣布无效。萨米亚对家人隐瞒了这个消息，并悄悄开始与阿里规划未来。四个多月后，两人结婚了。他们出现在那位曾解除萨米亚前一段婚姻的布拉德福德伊玛目家中。萨米亚在整个仪式中都很开心，面带微笑，甚至唱起了歌。十七天后，这对新婚夫妇签署了结婚登记册，完成了英国的法律手续。阿里很快不得不回迪拜工作。萨米亚必须等待她的配偶签证申请
to be approved before she could join him. In the meantime, she remained in Bradford with her family, whom she believed were unaware of what she had done. Case file will be back shortly. Thank you for supporting us by listening to this episode's sponsors. Thank you for listening to this episode's ads. Dads, by supporting our sponsors, you support CaseFile to continue to deliver quality content. Just over a month after her marriage to Arlee, Simea was walking through town one night when a man approached. He wielded a metal bar which he smashed across Simea's legs.
获批后才能去和他团聚。在此期间，她留在布拉德福德与家人住在一起，她以为家人不知道她所做的一切。Casefile 稍后回来。感谢您通过收听本集的赞助商来支持我们。感谢您收听本集的广告。通过支持我们的赞助商，您支持 Casefile 继续提供优质内容。在与阿里结婚一个多月后，一天晚上，萨米亚走在镇上时，一名男子走近她。他挥舞着一根金属棒，猛击萨米亚的腿部。
By the time Simea was taken to hospital, large red and purple bruises had formed across her thighs. She understood that the secret about her marriage to Ali was out. The attack on her was an act of retribution. The attack on her was an act of retribution. At the same time, the Imam who officiated Samir and Ali's wedding was warned that there would be consequences for his involvement. The threats had arisen from the Shahids, Samir's own family. Over the coming months, they ostracized Samimea further, with her mother throwing out all of her belongings.
当萨米亚被送往医院时，她的大腿上已经形成了大片红紫色的淤青。她明白，她与阿里结婚的秘密已经泄露。对她的袭击是一种报复行为。对她的袭击是一种报复行为。与此同时，主持萨米亚和阿里婚礼的伊玛目也收到警告，称他的参与将带来后果。这些威胁来自萨米亚自己的家人——沙希德一家。在接下来的几个月里，他们进一步排挤萨米亚，她的母亲甚至扔掉了她所有的个人物品。
The Shahid family also began threatening Ali, demanding he cut ties with Simea. The police were informed and acted accordingly, but the animosity between Simea and her family continued to grow. She became more frightened for her safety. In late May 2015, eight months after her wedding to Arle, Samia received her spousal visa. She fled to Dubai the very next day. Samia's happiness was evident in photos and updates she sent back to her friends in the UK.
沙希德一家还开始威胁阿里，要求他切断与萨米亚的联系。警方获悉后采取了相应行动，但萨米亚与家人之间的敌意持续加剧。她对自身安全的恐惧感日益增加。2015年5月下旬，在与阿里结婚八个月后，萨米亚拿到了配偶签证。第二天，她就逃往了迪拜。萨米亚发回给英国朋友的照片和动态中，明显流露出她的幸福。
Yet, the absence of her family weighed heavily on Simea. She reached out to her family nearly every day, asking for forgiveness. While Simea's mother and sister sometimes responded to her messages, her father ignored her completely. His silence hurt Simea profoundly. When Ali tried to appeal to Mahomet Shahid, he just demanded that Ali ended the marriage to his daughter. Ali refused. Samir and Ali wanted to have children.
然而，家人的缺席让萨米亚感到沉重。她几乎每天都联系家人，请求原谅。虽然萨米亚的母亲和妹妹有时会回复她的信息，但她的父亲完全无视她。他的沉默深深伤害了萨米亚。当阿里试图向马霍梅德·沙希德求情时，他只是要求阿里结束与他女儿的婚姻。阿里拒绝了。萨米亚和阿里想要孩子。
With this in mind, Samir returned to Bradford to extend the olive branch to her family. Her mother collected her from the airport and brought her home to see her father and sister. Samir kissed her dad and begged him for forgiveness. Everyone was in tears, and for a fleeting moment, Simea hoped that she would be welcomed back. However, the Pakistani traditions of family reputation and respect were deeply upheld by Muhammad Shahid and his extended family. In their eyes, Simea had brought great shame on the family by marrying Ali. Not only was he from outside the family, he wasn't even a member of the same faith. Simea's family was Sunni Muslims, whereas Ali and his family were Shia Muslims.
考虑到这一点，萨米亚回到布拉德福德，试图向家人示好。她的母亲从机场接她回家见父亲和妹妹。萨米亚亲吻了父亲，恳求他的原谅。所有人都泪流满面，那一刻，萨米亚曾短暂地希望自己能被接纳。然而，穆罕默德·沙希德及其大家族深深恪守着巴基斯坦关于家族声誉和尊严的传统。在他们眼中，萨米亚嫁给阿里给家族带来了巨大的耻辱。他不仅是外人，甚至不是同一个信仰的成员。萨米亚的家人是逊尼派穆斯林，而阿里及其家人是什叶派穆斯林。
A bitter and violent split dating back 14th centuries exist between the Sunnis and the Shias over who should succeed the Prophet Muhammad as the leader of the Islamic faith. In another perceived slight to her family, Samir had converted to the Shia Muslim faith prior to marrying Ali. Mahometra hid outright rejected his daughter. In a voice message left for Ali, Simea said, The parents that I cried for while I was away are mine no more. My kids will never see them, never hear them.
逊尼派和什叶派之间存在着长达14个世纪的痛苦而暴力的分裂，起因是关于谁应该继承先知穆罕默德成为伊斯兰信仰的领袖。在家人看来，萨米亚的另一个冒犯是她在嫁给阿里之前改信了什叶派。马霍梅德·沙希德彻底拒绝了自己的女儿。在留给阿里的一条语音信息中，萨米亚说：“我离家时为之哭泣的父母，不再是我的父母了。我的孩子们永远不会见到他们，永远不会听到他们的声音。”
I'm broken. That's it. My only pride is you, and you alone. Samia returned to Dubai devastated. 10 months later, in June 2016, 28-year-old Simea was informed that her ex-husband's mother had passed away. As well as being Simea's former mother-in-law, she was also her aunt. The pair had been markedly close during Simea's time in Pakistan. Simea desperately wanted to attend the funeral service in Pandori. Her parents and sister would also be there, granting her the opportunity to see them for the first time in almost
“我崩溃了。就是这样。我唯一的骄傲就是你，只有你。”萨米亚心碎地回到了迪拜。10个月后的2016年6月，28岁的萨米亚获悉她前夫的母亲去世了。她不仅是萨米亚的前婆婆，也是她的姑姑。萨米亚在巴基斯坦期间，两人关系非常亲密。萨米亚非常渴望参加在潘多里举行的葬礼。她的父母和妹妹也会在那里，这让她有机会在近一年来第一次见到他们。
a year. However, the trip was fraught with risk. Threats and attacks made against Samia in the UK for her alleged blasphemy had been restrained by prevailing Western customs and a British law. It was different in Pakistan. When a person brings shame upon their family, millennia-rolled Pakistani tradition dictates that honor can be restored by male family members murdering that person. In a society where some value the dominance of men
然而，这次旅行充满了风险。在英国，针对萨米亚所谓“亵渎”行为的威胁和攻击受到了西方习俗和英国法律的约束。但在巴基斯坦情况则不同。当一个人给家族带来耻辱时，延续千年的巴基斯坦传统规定，男性家族成员可以通过谋杀该人来恢复荣誉。在一个某些人推崇男性主导地位、女性必须谦逊顺从的社会里，大多数“荣誉谋杀”的受害者都是被男性亲属杀害的女孩和妇女。在巴基斯坦，许多行为都可能导致家族蒙羞，包括女性违背家人意愿结婚。尽管伊斯兰教法禁止，但“卡罗卡里”（Karokari）或荣誉谋杀的做法在巴基斯坦依然存在，尤其是在农村地区。萨米亚知道去巴基斯坦会危及生命。她的前夫乔杜里·沙基尔仍然住在那里，他和他的家人无疑会对萨米亚所谓的“不检点”行为有强烈的反应。
and the modesty and subservience of women, the majority of oner-killing victims are girls and women who are killed by male relatives. In Pakistan, many actions can lead to family dishonor, including when a woman marries against her family's wishes. Although forbidden under Sharia law, the practice of Karokari or honor killing has continued in Pakistan, especially in rural areas. Samir knew that traveling to Pakistan would put her life in danger. Her ex-husband, Chaudhry Shaqil, still lived there, and he and his family would no doubt
（注：原文第20段与第19段内容有重叠，此处按原文顺序翻译）
have strong feelings about Samir's perceived indiscretions. After mulling it over with her husband Ali, Samir decided that it wasn't wise for her to go to Pakistan. Several days after her aunt's funeral, Simea received word from her mother and sister. While they were in Pakistan, Simea's father had suffered complications in relation to his diabetes. His health had taken a turn for the worse,
在与丈夫阿里商量后，萨米亚认为去巴基斯坦并不明智。在姑姑葬礼几天后，萨米亚收到了母亲和妹妹的消息。她们在巴基斯坦时，萨米亚的父亲因糖尿病并发症病情恶化，
and they feared he didn't have much time left. Simea's family encouraged her to visit him. Despite the painful rejection, Simea still loved her father. Yet, she remained uncertain if Pakistan was safe for her. She messaged a friend. I want to go, but I have no assurances. While Semya's husband and friends agreed that she would likely never forgive herself if her father died without her by his side, they were adamant that she would be risking everything by returning to Pakistan.
她们担心他时日无多。萨米亚的家人鼓励她去探望他。尽管遭受了痛苦的拒绝，萨米亚依然爱着她的父亲。然而，她仍然不确定巴基斯坦对她来说是否安全。她给朋友发信息说：“我想去，但我没有任何保障。”虽然萨米亚的丈夫和朋友们都认为，如果父亲在没有她陪伴的情况下去世，她可能永远无法原谅自己，但他们坚信，回到巴基斯坦会让她冒失去一切的风险。
Semya made her decision. risking everything by returning to Pakistan. Sameer made her decision. Her sister booked her a plane ticket, and on Thursday, July 14, 2016, Sameer boarded her flight to Pakistan. Before she left, she messaged a friend, asking her to, quote, pray I come back alive. Simea's friend responded with one word, in Shahra'la, meaning God willing. During her first night in Pakistan, Simea stayed with a friend.
萨米亚做出了决定。冒着失去一切的风险回到巴基斯坦。萨米亚做出了决定。她的妹妹为她订了机票，2016年7月14日星期四，萨米亚登上了飞往巴基斯坦的航班。出发前，她给一位朋友发信息，请求她“祈祷我能活着回来”。萨米亚的朋友回复了一个词：“Insha'Allah”（意为“如果真主意欲”）。在巴基斯坦的第一晚，萨米亚住在一位朋友家。
She left her passport and returned ticket at their house for safekeeping. She then made her way to Pandori. Over the next few days, Simea sent several text messages to Ali, updating him on her plans and sending her love. She spent time with her mother, father and sister as well as extended family. On July 18, Semyya visited her aunt's grave with her father. Around noon on Wednesday July 20, she went to the Pakistani Bazaar to buy food for dinner. She messaged Ali, flying out tomorrow, her ball goes well, in Shah Al-Ala. About 90 minutes after Samir sent this message, the phone rang at the Pandori police station. On the line was Muhammad Shahid. He was distressed and crying and he informed the answering officer.
她把护照和返程机票留在朋友家妥善保管。随后她前往潘多里。接下来的几天里，萨米亚给阿里发了几条短信，告知他自己的计划并表达爱意。她与父母、妹妹以及大家族成员待在一起。7月18日，萨米亚与父亲一起拜访了姑姑的墓地。7月20日星期三中午左右，她去巴基斯坦集市买晚餐用的食物。她给阿里发信息：“明天飞回去，一切顺利，Insha'Allah。”在萨米亚发出这条信息约90分钟后，潘多里警察局的电话响了。电话那头是穆罕默德·沙希德。他情绪激动，哭着告诉接警的警官：
My daughter has died. My daughter has died. Police were directed to go to the home of Chaudhry-Shakil, where they found Samir Shahid lying motionless on her back at the foot of the stairs. Her scarf was covering her face. Police lifted it away gently, revealing that some of his eyes were closed and Froth had formed around her mouth. She was clearly deceased. Her slip on shoes were scattered nearby and her handbag had been placed by her feet. Chordry Shakyel was not at the scene and no one knew where he had gone. Later that evening, Ali Kasm received a phone call from Shakyel, who informed Ali that Case file will be back shortly. Thank you for supporting us by listening to this episode's sponsors.
“我女儿死了。我女儿死了。”警方被派往乔杜里·沙基尔的家中，发现萨米亚·沙希德一动不动地躺在楼梯脚下，面朝上。她的围巾遮住了脸。警察轻轻掀开围巾，发现萨米亚双眼紧闭，嘴边有白沫。她显然已经死亡。她的平底鞋散落在附近，手提包被放在她的脚边。乔杜里·沙基尔不在现场，没人知道他去了哪里。那天晚上晚些时候，阿里·卡兹姆接到了沙基尔的电话，沙基尔告诉阿里，Casefile 稍后回来。感谢您通过收听本集的赞助商来支持我们。
Thank you for listening to this episode's ads. By supporting our sponsors, you support CaseFile to continue to deliver quality content. Samiya's friends in the UK started receiving mixed messages about her cause of death. Some were told she died of a heart attack or a severe asthma attack, while others heard she fell down the stairs. Neither Simea's friends nor husband believed any of these explanations for a second. Within 72 hours of his wife's death, Ali Kasm flew to Pakistan to investigate the matter personally. He was immediately confronted with a significant problem.
感谢您收听本集的广告。通过支持我们的赞助商，您支持 Casefile 继续提供优质内容。萨米亚在英国的朋友们开始收到关于她死因的各种说法。有人被告知她死于心脏病或严重的哮喘发作，而另一些人则听说她从楼梯上摔了下来。萨米亚的朋友和丈夫一秒钟都没有相信这些解释。在妻子去世后的72小时内，阿里·卡兹姆飞往巴基斯坦亲自调查此事。他立即面临一个重大问题。
If a death isn't contentious, Sharia law requires burial to be swift. Allegedly, there were no visible injuries or signs of violence on Simea's body. Therefore police did not view her death as suspicious. Her body was hastily released to her family and within hours of her death, Simea had been buried in the village cemetery. Ali informed officers at Pandori's local police station of the threats and attacks leveled against his wife as a result of their marriage. With these new insights, officers considered the possibility that Simea was the victim of
如果死亡没有争议，伊斯兰教法要求迅速下葬。据称，萨米亚的尸体上没有明显的伤痕或暴力迹象。因此，警方并未将她的死亡视为可疑。她的尸体被匆忙移交给家人，在去世后的几个小时内，萨米亚就被埋葬在村里的墓地里。阿里向潘多里当地警察局的警官通报了因他们的婚姻而针对他妻子的威胁和袭击。有了这些新信息，警官们开始考虑萨米亚是“卡罗卡里”（荣誉谋杀）受害者的可能性。
a caro-carry, an honour killing. In the UK, Simea's friends worked diligently to raise awareness of Simea's death, which they undoubtedly believed was a murder. News of the case reached the local member of parliament for Simea's constituency of West Bradford, Naz Shah. Like Simea, Naz Shah was a British citizen of Pakistani descent, and she immediately recognized that Simea's death had all the attributes of an honor killing. She wasted no time writing to the Pakistani Prime Minister seeking a proper investigation
在英国，萨米亚的朋友们努力提高人们对萨米亚死亡事件的关注，他们毫无疑问地认为这是一起谋杀案。案件的消息传到了萨米亚所在的西布拉德福德选区的国会议员纳兹·沙（Naz Shah）耳中。和萨米亚一样，纳兹·沙也是巴基斯坦裔英国公民，她立即意识到萨米亚的死具有荣誉谋杀的所有特征。她毫不耽搁地写信给巴基斯坦总理，要求对萨米亚的死进行适当调查。
into Simea's death. As a result, Naz Shah started receiving threats from the Shahid family in Bradford. Two of Simea's relatives, a 32-year-old woman and a 37-year-old male, were arrested. In Pakistan, Ali Kasm got his hands on a copy of Simea's autopsy report. The contents shocked him, and he quickly arranged a press conference in order to announce the truth of his findings. A 19cm long reddish brown bruise had been found around Semyar's neck. The cause of her death had been listed as a sfixio. Photographs showing this bruise were leaked to the media. Ali remained in Pakistan determined to find out what exactly had happened to his wife.
结果，纳兹·沙开始收到来自布拉德福德沙希德一家的威胁。萨米亚的两名亲属，一名32岁的女性和一名37岁的男性被捕。在巴基斯坦，阿里·卡兹姆拿到了一份萨米亚的尸检报告副本。内容让他震惊，他迅速安排了一场新闻发布会，以公布调查结果的真相。萨米亚的脖子上发现了一道19厘米长的红褐色淤痕。她的死因被列为窒息。显示这道淤痕的照片被泄露给了媒体。阿里留在巴基斯坦，决心查明妻子到底发生了什么。
His efforts resulted in death threats, with Ali subsequently requiring 24 hour police protection. The rising political pressure resulted in a special task force being established to investigate Simea Shahid's death. In mid-August, weeks after she died, the task force tracked down Chordry Shaqil. During interrogation, Shaqil revealed that the morning before Samir was due to the part Pakistan, he rummaged through her belongings in search of her passport and flight ticket. Unable to find them, he confronted Samir and tried to pressure her to remain in Pakistan with him.
他的努力招致了死亡威胁，阿里随后需要24小时的警察保护。日益高涨的政治压力促使成立了一个特别工作组来调查萨米亚·沙希德的死亡。8月中旬，在她去世几周后，工作组找到了乔杜里·沙基尔。在审讯中，沙基尔透露，在萨米亚原定离开巴基斯坦的前一天早上，他在她的行李中翻找护照和机票。找不到后，他与萨米亚对质，并试图强迫她留在巴基斯坦和他在一起。
When she refused, Shaqil raped her. Traces of seminal fluid inside Simea's body were found to match Shaqil. After her ordeal, Simea tried to run out of the house. But Shaqil chased her down and strangled her to death with her own scarf. Shaqil was adamant that he had acted alone, but police weren't convinced. When they arrived at Shaqil's home that day Samir was killed, they were met with Muhammad Shahid. He outright told police that his daughter had died of a heart attack and kept this story up until Ali Kasm held his press conference revealing Samir's autopsy results. Muhammad then revised his previous statements to say that Samir had suicide.
当她拒绝时，沙基尔强奸了她。萨米亚体内发现的精液痕迹与沙基尔相符。经历这一切后，萨米亚试图跑出房子。但沙基尔追上她，用她自己的围巾将她勒死。沙基尔坚称他是单独行动的，但警方并不相信。当他们那天到达沙基尔家时，穆罕默德·沙希德也在场。他直接告诉警察，他的女儿死于心脏病，并一直坚持这个说法，直到阿里·卡兹姆举行新闻发布会公布了萨米亚的尸检结果。穆罕默德随后修改了之前的陈述，称萨米亚是自杀。
Muhammad had told police at the scene that Samir was married to and lived with Chaudhry Shaqil. He made no mention of Ali Kazim at the time, later claiming that he had never even heard of Ali. With his story failing to add up, Mahamad Shahid was taken into custody, believed to have at least been an accessory to his daughter's murder. According to a 43-page report prepared by the Special Investigation Task Force, Simea Shahid was the victim of a premeditated and cold blooded on a killing. Her family had felt disrespected by her attempt to divorce Chaudry Shaqil, and were further dishonored when Simea instead married a man who wasn't a Sunni Muslim. Shaqil was also angry that he could no longer immigrate to England as Simea's spouse.
穆罕默德在现场告诉警察，萨米亚与乔杜里·沙基尔结婚并住在一起。当时他只字未提阿里·卡兹姆，后来声称他甚至从未听说过阿里。由于他的说法漏洞百出，穆罕默德·沙希德被拘留，被认为至少是其女儿谋杀案的共犯。根据特别调查工作组编写的一份43页的报告，萨米亚·沙希德是一起蓄意且冷血的荣誉谋杀案的受害者。她的家人因她试图与乔杜里·沙基尔离婚而感到不被尊重，当萨米亚转而嫁给一个非逊尼派穆斯林的男人时，他们感到更加蒙羞。沙基尔也因为无法再以萨米亚配偶的身份移民英国而感到愤怒。
The report highlighted the campaign of threats against Simea over the preceding years, and the trepidation that she must have felt in returning to Pakistan. Investigators believed that Muhammad Shahid and Chaudhary Shakyel had always intended to bring Samia back to Pakistan. They likely intended to persuade or otherwise force her to resume her marriage to Shakyel. When she refused and tried to escape Shaqil's home, Samia was likely confronted by her father. It was believed he had held Samia's legs while Shaqil strangled her with her own scarf. After the murder, Shaqil fled, while Samia's father did everything he could to hide the truth from first responders.
报告强调了过去几年针对萨米亚的威胁活动，以及她回到巴基斯坦时必然感到的恐惧。调查人员认为，穆罕默德·沙希德和乔杜里·沙基尔一直打算把萨米亚带回巴基斯坦。他们很可能打算说服或以其他方式强迫她恢复与沙基尔的婚姻。当她拒绝并试图逃离沙基尔的家时，萨米亚很可能与父亲发生了冲突。据信，他按住了萨米亚的腿，而沙基尔用她自己的围巾勒死了她。谋杀发生后，沙基尔逃跑了，而萨米亚的父亲竭尽全力向急救人员隐瞒真相。
The task force believed that Muhammad Shahid knew that the post-mortem results would reveal that his daughter had been strangled. If those results were leaked, they believed that Muhammad Shahid had a backup plan to lodge his own private prosecution against Shakyel Fenerda. a backup plan to lodge his own private prosecution against Shaqil for murder. Deeply rooted in Islamic law and codified by Pakistanis' penal code is the concept of retributive justice, known as Qasars. However, it is possible to circumvent such an eye for an eye approach through a deit, a payment in lieu of punishment. Muhammad Shahid would have been able to renounce his right to have his daughter's killer sent
工作组认为，穆罕默德·沙希德知道尸检结果会显示他的女儿是被勒死的。如果这些结果泄露，他们认为穆罕默德·沙希德有一个备用计划，即针对沙基尔提起私人诉讼。深植于伊斯兰法并被巴基斯坦刑法典编纂的是一种被称为“Qisas”（同态复仇）的报复性正义概念。然而，可以通过“Diyat”（以赔偿代替惩罚）来规避这种“以眼还眼”的方法。如果凶手支付经济赔偿，穆罕默德·沙希德本可以放弃让女儿的凶手入狱或被处决的权利。这种漏洞经常被用于荣誉谋杀案中。
to prison or possibly executed if the killer instead paid him financial compensation. This loophole is often utilized in honor killings. Muhammad and Chaudhry Shaqil likely planned to use these, quote, blood money laws to pardon Shaqil for killing Samia. The task force report noted that the collusion between Shaqil and Muhammad Shahid was almost the perfect plot. Had it not been for Ali Q Cazam's immediate determination to uncover the truth, they would have gotten away with murder. Mahometra hid and Chordry Shakyal applied for bail at each preliminary hearing in the district court. They were denied each time.
穆罕默德和乔杜里·沙基尔很可能计划利用这些所谓的“血钱法”来赦免沙基尔杀害萨米亚的行为。特别工作组的报告指出，沙基尔和穆罕默德·沙希德之间的勾结几乎是一个完美的阴谋。如果不是因为阿里·卡兹姆立即揭露真相的决心，他们本可以逍遥法外。马霍梅德·沙希德和乔杜里·沙基尔在地区法院的每次预审听证会上都申请保释。但每次都被拒绝。
After four months in jail, Muhammad appealed to the high court of Lahore. The judges determined that there wasn't enough evidence against him to justify his continued custody. The state prosecutor appealed to Pakistan Supreme Court. However, the court upheld the ruling. Muhammad Shahid was released. The case against the Chaudhry Shaqil was much stronger, but not watertight.
在监狱里待了四个月后，穆罕默德向拉合尔高等法院提出上诉。法官裁定，没有足够的证据证明他继续被拘留的合理性。州检察官向巴基斯坦最高法院提出上诉。然而，法院维持了原判。穆罕默德·沙希德被释放了。针对乔杜里·沙基尔的案件证据要充分得多，但并非无懈可击。
In Pakistan, confessions made outside of a court of law have no legal standing and cannot be used as evidence against an accused. This practice is designed to eliminate the risk of coerced confessions. Shaqil remained in custody, albeit without formal charges being laid. By the time the one-year anniversary of Simea Shihid's murder approached, no tangible progress had been made towards a trial. In response to the slow-turning wheels of justice, Bradford West's member of parliament Naz Shah once again wrote to the Pakistani Prime Minister, urging him to pursue justice for Simea. Naz Shah received the appropriate assurances, but still nothing seemed to be
在巴基斯坦，在法庭外做出的供词没有法律效力，不能作为针对被告的证据。这种做法旨在消除强迫供词的风险。沙基尔仍被拘留，尽管尚未正式起诉。当萨米亚·沙希德谋杀案一周年临近时，审判仍未取得实质性进展。为了回应缓慢的司法进程，西布拉德福德国会议员纳兹·沙再次写信给巴基斯坦总理，敦促他为萨米亚伸张正义。纳兹·沙得到了相应的保证，但似乎什么也没做。
done. Six months later, in late January 2018, Muhammad Shahid was hospitalized. He succumbed to kidney failure and passed away. Neither Muhammad's wife, M.T.H.B.E his daughter, M.D.H. were at his side when he died. A warrant was out for their arrest in Pakistan. The task force fronting the investigation into Simea Shahid's murder had reviewed the possibility of others being involved. They had come to believe that Simea's mother and sister played some incillary role in Simea's
六个月后，即2018年1月底，穆罕默德·沙希德住院。他因肾衰竭去世。穆罕默德去世时，他的妻子和女儿都不在他身边。巴基斯坦对他发出了逮捕令。负责调查萨米亚·沙希德谋杀案的工作组审查了其他人参与的可能性。他们开始相信萨米亚的母亲和妹妹在萨米亚的
death. But when they tried to bring them in for further questioning, they discovered that both women had fled back to the UK. In 2018, Simea's sister, Madihha granted an exclusive interview with British tabloid, Asian Express. In the interview, she expressed her family's ongoing belief that Simea's marriage to Chaudhry Shaquille was legal and to not forced. Madiha said that she and her family were emotionally torn and couldn't understand Simea's sudden
死亡中扮演了某种辅助角色。但当他们试图传唤她们进行进一步询问时，发现这两名女性都已经逃回了英国。2018年，萨米亚的妹妹梅迪哈接受了英国小报《亚洲快报》的独家采访。在采访中，她表达了家人一贯的信念，即萨米亚与乔杜里·沙基尔的婚姻是合法的，而非强迫的。梅迪哈说，她和她的家人在情感上很痛苦，无法理解萨米亚的突然
death. She referred to it as a tragic accident, while claiming the photographs showing the strangulation mark around her sister's neck were fake. Madiha proclaimed that she and her family were innocent, and that their lives had been ruined by, quote, a false narrative calling this an honour killing from the outset. MTA's BB and Madiha Shahid are still wanted for questioning by Pakistani authorities. Investigators also found evidence implicating local police officer Muhammad Akhil Abbas in covering up the crime.
死亡。她称这是一场悲剧性的意外，同时声称显示她姐姐脖子上勒痕的照片是伪造的。梅迪哈宣称她和她的家人是无辜的，他们的生活被“从一开始就称其为荣誉谋杀的虚假叙事”所毁。萨米亚的母亲和梅迪哈·沙希德仍被巴基斯坦当局通缉。调查人员还发现了当地警官穆罕默德·阿基尔·阿巴斯（Muhammad Akhil Abbas）掩盖罪行的证据。
Abbas was one of the first officers on the scene after Simea's death. It is alleged that he had accepted a bribe from Chaudhry Shakil in order to let him flee the crime scene. Abbas had also concealed the presence of the large strangulation mark around Simea's neck. Additionally, he'd helped Simea's mother and sister leave Pakistan, despite specific instructions from his superiors not to let them go. Eleven weeks after Simea's murder, the Pakistan Parliament passed a bill to close the blood
阿巴斯是萨米亚死后第一批到达现场的警官之一。据称，他接受了乔杜里·沙基尔的贿赂，以便让他逃离犯罪现场。阿巴斯还隐瞒了萨米亚脖子上那道巨大的勒痕。此外，尽管上级明确指示不要让她们离开，他还是帮助萨米亚的母亲和妹妹离开了巴基斯坦。萨米亚被谋杀11周后，巴基斯坦议会通过了一项法案，以堵住关于荣誉谋杀的“血钱”法律漏洞。
money legal loophole with regard to water killings. The new bill amended the Pakistan Penal Code so that the family of an oner-killing victim could no longer entirely forgive the perpetrator on receipt of financial compensation. Instead, the perpetrator would face a mandatory life sentence. In September 2018, after having spent two years in police custody with our charge, Chaudhry-Shakil was released on bail. He was permitted to live freely within his community while awaiting trial. A year later, Shaqil remarried. Like Samia, his wife was British Pakistani, and Shaqil once again applied Shah again wrote to the Pakistan Prime Minister, as well as the British home and foreign secretaries.
新法案修订了《巴基斯坦刑法典》，规定荣誉谋杀受害者的家属不能再通过接受经济赔偿来完全原谅肇事者。相反，肇事者将面临强制性的终身监禁。2018年9月，在未经指控被警方拘留两年后，乔杜里·沙基尔被保释出狱。在等待审判期间，他被允许在社区内自由生活。一年后，沙基尔再婚。和萨米亚一样，他的妻子也是英籍巴基斯坦人，沙基尔再次申请（签证）。纳兹·沙再次写信给巴基斯坦总理，以及英国内政大臣和外交大臣。
She labelled the potential for Shaqil to be allowed entry into the UK as extremely worrying and potentially dangerous. Shaqil's application was unsuccessful. Every year since, Naz Shah renewed her appeals to both British and Pakistani authorities to encourage progress in the case against Shaqial. Promises have been made, but no action has been taken. In July 2022, 60s after Simea's murder, Naz Shah posted online. Sadly, after years of fighting for this case, I think there is little hope that the Justice she deserves. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
她称沙基尔可能获准进入英国的情况“极其令人担忧且具有潜在危险”。沙基尔的申请未获成功。此后的每一年，纳兹·沙都重申她对英国和巴基斯坦当局的呼吁，以推动针对沙基尔案件的进展。承诺已经做出，但没有采取任何行动。2022年7月，在萨米亚被谋杀6年后，纳兹·沙在网上发帖称：“可悲的是，在为这个案件奋斗了多年之后，我认为她应得的正义几乎没有希望了。”目前还没有关于本集的评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。